then tied up I need someone to come and
save me I wished it I wish they'd hurry
up and thank me hi nice
Kentucky people off wait
[Applause]
[Music]
frame do people do impressions of people
who do impressions of you don't know
very rarely yeah
Perry right yeah why am I in your cabin
it's like I always I feel like and I
wouldn't be able to do it until I met
you but I have I don't know so I'm kind
of the cards I need the car okay don't
worry never all over the car there's no
card
[Applause]
I feel your pain ball
there's a first time for everything
but impressions of a thing that actors
do probably you do an impression I do
bad impersonation of Sir Ian McKellen a
scoundrel you said that passion on flem
demand ding dong ding dong bang on
column and Gollum I was in Waitrose the
supermarket here and they have those
self-service checkouts so I was at the
other checkout and Ian McKellan I said
hello to him earlier he's wandering
around the basket and I was trigger and
then just over in the self service area
you just heard this booming voice going
you did me and you were very good you
did my laugh very well you learnt some
special skills I believe for this film
that's right
as I was saying the parkour elements so
I got to perfect the Rollie pollie you
must have known how to do Rollie pollie
at one time in your life so you could do
not now I'm 53 do a Rollie pollie you
think you can do a Rollie pollies I have
tried that's right it's a head over
heels that's a problem you have to do it
with me yes you can
[Music]
[Applause]
it look like a bball it would look like
a beus in a nursing home it will live
some have beds and you're kicking them
down the collar go okay exactly you do
it first okay you do it first so
basically you're mine I'm gonna end up
off the stage oh but you are you gonna
do a let me know so basically you have
to keep your hand
I thought you would just do that
so I could never do that but I place
your forearm down first and then tuck
your head over
I'm here in case you go off the edge
really pay that to you yeah so you
forearm yeah and then tuck your shoulder
over and stay on that side don't go
straight down your spine okay so think
about it too much
this pit here yeah hand this pit and
then just roll it okay so I'm never I
won't get over
[Applause]
I got you see something there from a
third pair students point of view of
something that I've been a part of many
many times which exam City Michael I
don't think I can keep going you know
yeah you can just really quietly and
comfortably carry you can it look like
an advert for injury lawyers for you
there I was standing there at the church
first time in my life I realized I
[Music]
[Music]
it wasn't the person standing next to me
[Music]
there was a person standing opposite man
is it still raining like you're on a
suit but can you do the deadlift thing
space
Hey
okay don't now slam me on my face we're
gonna set you down Jenna thank you thank
you and where you from Rebecca New
Zealand
please prise me so this is a situation
where we're allowed to one of us pulls
this lever
she flips yeah okay
[Applause]
hi ru hi I just like to say that I think
Matt Damon is really amazing in the
fourth ball this is the best time I've
ever had on a talk show
[Applause]
[Music]